okay carrie we are in the back half of
season five
i feel like it's been a tougher season
for you than you are anticipating
how are you feeling about it i had a
really rough
uh start at the beginning you know um
and you know but you know i think it's
getting better how have you been
handling the criticism though
i would say that i'm very disappointed
about the
that the people call me a bully you know
because obviously i don't feel like i'm
a bully i mean
yes in my confrontational yes and my
advice be
yes you know but that's very different
than being a bully
and that that does hurt my feelings but
you know i'm hoping that
eventually people will see through me
and they'll move on i mean i can't
control how people feel
people are going to be like that and i
feel like you know if you take the time
to go
on my account and say all these things
about me i mean
isn't that bullying it's a good point
what you're doing to me so okay but i
mean it's obvious that you
love fun you want people to have fun i
think
in my watching and i'm like maybe a
lesson for carrie this year was
not everyone's fun is the same as her
definition of fun
has that been a learning for you oh a
thousand percent yeah
typically come here
[Music]
i'm not going to be pushing anybody into
bottles of water
you shouldn't want your swimming suit
man in the last couple episodes we've
seen you and
tiffany seem to to grow into a
friendship seem to get to a better place
but then i think about
the social media from the the beginning
of the season and it
it seems like maybe you went back to the
place you were in where do things stand
with tiffany now
well you know what happened when i
started seeing uh the
show and she's feeling a certain way
about me and
talking behind my back it hurt my
feelings
because i've given her opportunities for
her to come to me and talk to me about
it and so yeah i mean i did
call her a snake you know but it's kind
of like
i felt like she was a little bit and
then she you know
unfollow me on on instagram and
everything else so i am following her
you know
and she's never made an effort with me i
mean i know she's made an effort
with stephanie and cameron off season a
lot she's texted them
and really tried to be their friend and
she's never done that to me but
i felt that from tiffany honestly since
the beginning of the season
and i just felt feel like she really did
never wanted to be my friend and
and it makes me very sad so that whole
the whole experience with tiffany has
really been
very disappointed and then you and
d'andra it's it has been a little bit of
a journey
and i talked to deandra it seems like
she was
cautious about re-entering the
friendship with you at the level it used
to be where are you at
yes yeah i feel actually the same way
i guess i'm disappointed again that i
kind of put all
myself out there and and try to be
friends with someone and then
um you know why she feels like that way
with me i have no clue because i've been
nothing
nothing but a good friend of ours but uh
you know
we can have a superficial friendship and
if that's what it's going to end up and
that's i hope not
you know i hope we can really move past
that and
and hopefully be good friends but you
know
two people want to have to want it you
know two people have to want it
have to work at it friendships and close
relationships are not easy
it seems like you two might have
different definitions of what
that level of friendship means i was
listening to an interview she did and
she said she felt the need to like put a
reminder in her calendar to call you so
that
that wasn't an issue that she hadn't
called you yeah i said that to me before
i'm like okay then it makes sense you
know
i don't want to feel like you have to
come you should want to call me
if you have to put a reminder in your
phone to call me that means you have no
interest in talking to me
fair point i do think it's been really
nice to see you
as a mom this season though it's not
something we've got to really dig into
last year
um and olivia just breakout star of
season five
her confessionals are amazing
you wouldn't think that my mom's voice
would be a comforting voice to hear
but it's it's oddly satisfying
what's been your reaction to one seeing
what she's saying in those confessionals
and to her impression of you in those
confessionals
i'm going to be 50. oh it's my last time
cooking dinner for my four little
chickalini dunklings being 49.
eduardo what are you gonna get me for my
50th birthday
no one cares that you're turning 15.
olivia you know she's just like me
she's just gonna be so honest i mean i
love her so much and
she's a little firecracker and you know
i'm so proud of her that she put herself
out there this season
to help so many people i was literally
like driving to work and i texted my mom
i think if i don't see a therapist soon
like something bad is gonna happen it's
just so worth it and you know
and i'm just proud of her i'm so glad
that she's enjoying it and she's
being able to be herself she's just
you know a very special girl so she's
gotten some good out of it she feels
like it was good to share her story
and then we're just starting to dig into
this story of you
and your own mother we got to see a
little bit of your mom on the show
on facetime are we going to see more of
that this season or was that phone call
kind of what it was
no i had a lot of phone calls with my
mom and i'm not sure you know
what's gonna make make tv or not but
yeah yeah i mean it was a big
a year with me and my mom i mean and i'm
so happy because
we haven't really had a good
relationship ever since i can remember
and we finally are
i have a relationship when we never have
and i'm glad that i am able to have that
before it's too late
to break the fourth wall a little bit do
you think
being on the show and having this
platform encouraged that to happen
like do you think you would be in that
good of a place if it weren't for real
housewives
huh that's an interesting question i
mean
i definitely think that uh it's pushed
me
to look at myself and like what's in
your life that you need to
fix what's in your life that needs
closure you know what's going on
so as you know reality we can have
negative things for sure but
i feel like i've had so many positive
things that have happened
and you know like my relationship with
my mom and my kids
it's been a huge part of it and for that
and i'm very thankful for you know
well you've made closer friendships with
these women who i know
somewhere in your life before the show
but not everyone was in your life or
they weren't
at the level that they are now one of
those people is brandy who's also having
a pretty tough season and it seems like
it's going to continue
in the next episode simmons 50 till 56
of redmond's scandal
why couldn't you just say i don't want
to comment you took that away from me
deandra do you think i'm selfish that's
fine
talk me through that moment what are we
going to see there and what's the
fallout of that confrontation
you know uh we all know that brandy had
a really really
tough time with the videos and that's
that was her story to tell
and that's a moment that the android
tools go away for brandy
and i think you know that was not her
place to talk about it at all i mean
diandra
out of any one of us she knows how
mediocre works
she knows what she should say or not say
and what was going to make a headline
she used it you know because
i know she was trying to promote a movie
that she did
and she used the brandy and there to
to be the headline and i just don't
think that it was
uh fair to brandy to do that and
you know and brandi was really hurt
randy you know she
posted this cryptic thing there's been
other conversations around her personal
life do you think this is it for her is
she done with the show
i think that brandi is going to have to
make whatever best decision is for her i
don't think she was ready to come back
to season
and i think she still she's she's had a
really tough year
she needs to figure it out i think after
reigning i know reunion's fast
approaching andy tweeted out that
they're
gearing up for it so how are you gearing
up for the reunion is there anything
that you really want to get to the
bottom of there or clear up there
yeah i mean i'm just gonna go you know i
don't have any preparations i'm just me
i just show up
and i'm all like i i i'm not like i i
tiffany hurst she said that she's like
has
all her note cards ready to go cameron
is the same way
it was a great year's season filming
and we really tried to make it fun and
special considering we had so many
restraints because of covet and we
couldn't really go anywhere
and we made it really fun can you at
least admit that
maybe your birthday celebration went on
a little too long
we celebrated your birthday a lot of
times yes i know
i celebrated my birthdays the whole
month anyway
in general so but i mean you know yeah
it was a lot of episodes but
you know i i had fun for sure during the
big 501 acting like i was turning 21.
i think that's the way to do it though
yeah
you have to have fun you have to party
the thing that really cracked me up on
this last episode though
the nine commandments carrie
oh my gosh i mean i think we've all done
like
as a group things that it says in the
bible not to do right well use the nine
commandments i think we
nine we're like carrick you have not
read the bible
which which one did you eliminate i want
to know
are you kidding me i grew up catholic
like what was wrong with me
what are i guess then the nine
commandments to you what are carrie
brittingham's nine commandments
oh my gosh i mean okay so do not lie
do not uh you know sleep with that
neighbor
do not uh steal do not kill
you know uh oh gosh
i don't even i don't know them all well
i was getting
i was saying you should make up some of
your own you should come up with nine
that are just for you
oh then i go like yeah you have to drink
tequila
you have to you have to party like it's
[Music]
1999.
you